Nina has magical powers I discovered
yeah she can freeze things the kids
so I'm very excited well next time we
need to plan better that's it plan
better
all right last full days in New York
last full day in New York uh Evan and I
went uh we had an appointment this
morning and then we came back pick up
the kids and now we're off to see
stranger things Avengers have to decide
whether we're gonna Uber or we're gonna
take the subway
all right let's go
all right we're gonna pick up some
snacks before we head to the next
special things
foreign
it was a good sandwich
but I didn't really enjoy it
well next time I need to plan better
that's it plan better
[Music]
all right our next stop is the stranger
thing Hayden loved the stranger things
so we made a trip up here to see it
[Music]
I think we cannot film anything inside
so we're gonna enjoy and respect their
roots and enjoy ourselves we will let
you know how we like it
stay tuned
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
how's the stranger thing Evan
you like it it's good yeah I like it
it's actually pretty fun Nina has
magical powers I discovered yeah
yeah freezing
all right we've finished the stranger
thing let me take out my glasses the
kids doesn't want to walk two hours in
Brooklyn so with this I just go back to
the hotel chill a little bit and walk
around the uh cover
Harbor
oh my God I can't even say it okay
whatever we're gonna walk around after
okay go home go back chill
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dinner was good how would you rate it
Hayden oh
does she plays
let's give it
11.
11 out of ten Max you can get for me is
12.
Jeffrey
20 out of 10. okay good that's a very
high score my system is um weird
yeah it goes to 12. okay but out of ten
Okay evan how well how would you rate
the restaurant pretty good what's what's
the number number
I gave it a five star because Jeffrey
liked it
[Music]
this is our day five basically just our
travel day we had a good time we're just
getting filled up the fit out the car no
fill the gas into the car get a full ton
of gas okay I don't know what I just
said whatever I just need to get excited
to go with it okay guys yeah and then
we're gonna head home we're very gassy
no
oh
that's it yeah we have eight hours on
the road
we will be on the road for eight hours
okay it's very early I didn't really
sleep much less oh no yeah oh that's why
I can't really say anything anyways
we're gonna go home yay they're saying
beautiful things I miss my bed it's you
get it tonight for one night and then
one two nights or two nights yeah all
right let's go home
[Music]
we're going to stop at Manhattan Bagel
pick up some breakfast
because these monkeys are hungry
[Music]
so how was the breakfast seven pretty
good I'm not used to eating in the
morning uh okay kind of feeling very
good
nice Hot Bagels no one finished it oh
actually Jeffy finish yeah
yeah you still have a half a sandwich
yeah it was good yeah it's good filling
meal for the road
foreign
[Music]
ER just waiting to cross the border
creating Friday I don't even know
let's go get us through
foreign
[Music]
we got through the custom pretty easy
yep and quick
Evan maybe stutter a little bit what
yeah
yeah what stuttered
if you mess with my man I'm gonna be the
one who brings it to you okay just stop
singing all right we have an hour and a
half left we're gonna go home and chill
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what did you last film the dogs
the dog came back in oh the dogs came
back in we ate dinner we relaxed we need
to uh oh look who wants to join hello
hello girl come on she she missed us did
you miss us well
we missed you we missed you and here's
the exciting thing tomorrow we have a
full day we gotta cleanup and we need to
celebrate Nina's brother's birthday and
uh unpack wash our clothes and then
repack because we're going to Disney the
next day in Universal Studios for
another nine day trip
back to back so if you want to see day
one of our Disney trip check the video
right there next to us we'll see you
there continue to believe